hablamos de revista de prensa por
supuesto con quien más si no es rosa
pérez más seguro rosa bienvenida feliz
viernes ya cerramos esta semana del
programa y vamos ahora a ver una
revelación en esta sección de
potenciales crímenes de guerra en siria
cometidos por el ejército del presidente
bashar al-assad rosa durante los
primeros años de guerra el relato los
escribe martin chulov buenos días raúl
exactamente esto se trata de la masacre
de tadamun sería la matanza de al menos
41 civiles a manos de dos oficiales del
ejército sirio de hecho de ahmad yusef
un oficial de la inteligencia militar
siria en colaboración con una jeep al
halaby de una milicia pro asad también
que colabora a la práctica con el
ejército regular en este caso pues estas
imágenes han sido calificadas como de
muy importantes porque muestran
precisamente con mucha claridad
potenciales crímenes de guerra como
decías cometidas por el propio ejército
sirio de hecho raúl si te parece veamos
un extracto de estas imágenes publicadas
en un vídeo explicativo por el propio
medio de garcía
josetxo estas imágenes muestran una
masacre cometida en los suburbios al sur
de damasco en 2013
guau y si lo que vemos son grupos de
detenidos civiles que han sido
acorralados que se dirigen hacia una
fosa de ejecución con los ojos vendados
y maniatados y a los que se ordenó que
corrieran mientras corren son disparados
mortalmente por un oficial de la
inteligencia siria su nombre es ansia y
ustedes han de ir ser
es impactante rosa si más adelante en
las imágenes de hecho se ve se ven más
ejecuciones y también como queman a los
cuerpos no es de 16 recordemos de abril
de 2003 y tal y como destaca el propio
periodista el corresponsal de the
gardian en medio oriente así como los
investigadores que han analizado las
imágenes una de las cosas destacables es
como en la actitud y el aspecto de los
civiles que son ejecutados muestran como
no no estaban prisioneros no sino que de
hecho fueron seguramente sacados de sus
casas o incluso interceptados no en la
calle y que en algunos casos incluso
creían que el ejército les estaba
ofreciendo protección de francotiradores
por la forma en cómo les hacen correr
etcétera bueno raúl si es escalofriante
si estas imágenes de rosa y eso fue lo
que desencadenó la masacre digamos se
sabe que fue el origen de esta masacre
pues tal y como explican los
investigadores podría ser desde un
castigo colectivo por cualquier
vinculación con la oposición
el ejército libre de siria en ese
momento o pues hasta un mensaje letal
para los propios civiles suburbio del
sur de damasco de que no se pasarán pues
con la oposición no de hecho y es que en
ese momento la línea de frente entre el
ejército de al asad y pues el ejército
libre de siria estaba muy cerca de este
suburbio sur de damasco porque sale el
uso ahora ruso bien pues por un lado
porque la fuente que accedió en primer
lugar a estas imágenes ya está a salvo
en europa pero por otro lado cabe
explicar un poco cómo han llegado a
salir a la luz no estas pruebas y es que
hace tres años de hecho estas
filmaciones llegaron a manos de un
miliciano novato tal y como se describe
en el texto que pues las vio un poco por
casualidad en un vídeo del ejército
sirio horrorizado consideró que estas
pruebas tenían que salir a la luz las
mandó a una persona de la oposición
siria refugiada en francia que a su vez
las mandó a dos investigadores que
investigaban los crímenes de guerra del
ejército sirio basados en ámsterdam y la
forma como estos investigadores llegan
raúl a identificar a los autores de la
masacre bueno es una historia paralela
como decíamos crean un perfil falso de
facebook porque dicen que en esta
plataforma los militares sirios
comparten pues a muchas de sus
experiencias un perfil de una chica afín
al régimen de al asad que digamos
estaría investigando el conflicto
mientras pues estudia en el extranjero
de esta forma se ganan la confianza de
la persona que lidera la masacre que
llega a confesarles que él pues si mató
a muchas personas vengándose de la
muerte de su hermano y de hecho raúl y
al final le confiesan a este hombre que
son investigadores que van a llegar
estas pruebas a distintas fiscalías
europeas como ya es el caso en francia
alemania y países bajos donde pues están
investigando estos potenciales crímenes
contra la humanidad terrible no roza lo
que vemos la crueldad del ser humano
gracias por esta revista de prensa y los
invitamos también a que dan the gardian
y new line donde pueden ver toda esta
investigación rosa muchísimas gracias
por eso más ayudar a nuestro primer
invitado el día
[Música]